okay so mesenchymal stem cells for gvhd
um okay so we know that uh patients who are steroid resistant with acute gvhd they carry
double the amount of nrm risk as compared to those who are um steroid sensitive we know from
the reach to clinical trial um that um uh ruxolitinib does show that there is an overall
response of 62 however that leaves us with so 38 of patients who do not respond by day
28 and even those who did respond initially we see that there is a drop by day 56 we also know
that once patients become ruxolitinib refractory actually the day 100 mortality can go down to 80
and at that point really the survival is measured in weeks so essentially there is a huge unmet need
for steroid refraction
mesenchymal stem cells those are pluripotent cells that they can home to where the injury
and the inflammation is using cxcr4 and other adhesion molecules once they're in that environment
they secrete cytokines and through the pericrine effect and signaling they can communicate with
cells around them and that leads to immunomodulation and t-cell suppression as well
as they aid in the tissue repair they have properties that they
may not be able to control but they may be able to control the tissue repair
they have properties that they may be able to control but they may be able to control the tissue
repair they have properties that they may be able to control the tissue repair
ideal for the treatment of gvhd such as you don't need hla matching um since they don't have an
mhc class 2 expression they do not need to be engrafted in order to have their effect
and they're truthfully a great off-the-shelf allogeneic very scalable product
so we know that the very first uh clinical trial was a phase three that looked at
bone marrow derived mesenchymal cells this is the most commonly used source
and um this is a very common source of mesenchymal cells and this is a very common source of mesenchymal
cells and this is a very common source of mesenchymal cells and this is a very common source of
mesenchymal cells and this is a very common source of mesenchymal cells
and um this is a phase three that looked at mscs with um or without a second um line
now this is a multi-center study in 72 centers 70 country seven countries and so you can see
that there is a huge heterogeneity in terms of what each center was using as a second line
it did not meet its primary endpoint which is durable cr however um the post-hoc analysis
did show that there are certain certain subgroup of patients who do actually benefit from
mscs and this is a phase three that looked at mscs with um or without a second line
it did not meet its primary endpoint which is durable cr however um the post-hoc analysis
it did not meet its primary endpoint which is durable cr however um the post-hoc analysis mscs and those are patients with liver
mscs and those are patients with liver
mscs and those are patients with liver gvh involvement
gvh involvement
gvh involvement high-risk acute gvhd as well as the
high-risk acute gvhd as well as the
high-risk acute gvhd as well as the pediatric subgroup
pediatric subgroup
pediatric subgroup so when we remove the heterogeneity from
so when we remove the heterogeneity from
so when we remove the heterogeneity from the clinical trial and only focus on the
the clinical trial and only focus on the
the clinical trial and only focus on the pediatrics
pediatrics
pediatrics this trial looked at mscs um against
this trial looked at mscs um against
this trial looked at mscs um against best available treatment and it did
best available treatment and it did
best available treatment and it did actually reach its primary endpoint
actually reach its primary endpoint
actually reach its primary endpoint showing that the overall response was
showing that the overall response was
showing that the overall response was 70 percent as compared to the 45 percent
70 percent as compared to the 45 percent
70 percent as compared to the 45 percent historical control and then those
historical control and then those
historical control and then those patients um who did respond initially
patients um who did respond initially
patients um who did respond initially have an a day hundred overall survival
have an a day hundred overall survival
have an a day hundred overall survival of 87 percent as compared to 47 percent
of 87 percent as compared to 47 percent
of 87 percent as compared to 47 percent and as you know this led to the fda
and as you know this led to the fda
and as you know this led to the fda approval of
approval of
approval of rhinoceros as of december of last year
umbilical cord mesenchymal cells um have
umbilical cord mesenchymal cells um have been tested in the phase two
been tested in the phase two
been tested in the phase two uh trial in china that is a multi-center
uh trial in china that is a multi-center
uh trial in china that is a multi-center as well seven uh centers it didn't meet
as well seven uh centers it didn't meet
as well seven uh centers it didn't meet um the primary endpoint of overall
um the primary endpoint of overall
um the primary endpoint of overall survival at day 28 however the per
survival at day 28 however the per
survival at day 28 however the per protocol
protocol
protocol group the patients who did receive the
group the patients who did receive the
group the patients who did receive the eight infusions
eight infusions
eight infusions did show an overall response of 72 percent
did show an overall response of 72 percent
did show an overall response of 72 percent as compared to the ones um who didn't
as compared to the ones um who didn't
as compared to the ones um who didn't receive the infusion
receive the infusion
receive the infusion interestingly patients with gi uh
interestingly patients with gi uh
interestingly patients with gi uh involvement had an overall response of
involvement had an overall response of
involvement had an overall response of 66 percent
66 percent
66 percent compared to 33 which actually led to
compared to 33 which actually led to
compared to 33 which actually led to the conditional approval
the conditional approval
the conditional approval for specifically patients with gi
for specifically patients with gi
for specifically patients with gi involvement
there are other sources such as cord
there are other sources such as cord blood tissue
blood tissue
blood tissue derived mscs we know that they share
derived mscs we know that they share
derived mscs we know that they share the same phenotype in surface molecules as
the same phenotype in surface molecules as
the same phenotype in surface molecules as bone marrow derived however they
bone marrow derived however they
bone marrow derived however they actually can
actually can
actually can expand faster and they can double the
expand faster and they can double the
expand faster and they can double the number within shorter amount of time
number within shorter amount of time
number within shorter amount of time as compared to the bone marrow derived we
as compared to the bone marrow derived we
as compared to the bone marrow derived we see that they have an increased and
see that they have an increased and
see that they have an increased and prolonged biodistribution as you see in
prolonged biodistribution as you see in
prolonged biodistribution as you see in red compared to the blue which is bone
red compared to the blue which is bone
red compared to the blue which is bone marrow and they have a higher presence
marrow and they have a higher presence
marrow and they have a higher presence in the liver as compared to bone marrow
in the liver as compared to bone marrow
in the liver as compared to bone marrow so we have a phase one
so we have a phase one
so we have a phase one uh pilot study that is testing core
uh pilot study that is testing core
uh pilot study that is testing core tissue-derived mesenchymal cells
tissue-derived mesenchymal cells
tissue-derived mesenchymal cells uh with bruxolitinib and it's testing
uh with bruxolitinib and it's testing
uh with bruxolitinib and it's testing low and high doses of mesenchymal cells
low and high doses of mesenchymal cells
low and high doses of mesenchymal cells the primary endpoint for the study is
the primary endpoint for the study is
the primary endpoint for the study is testing day 28
testing day 28
testing day 28 um overall response as well as toxicity
um overall response as well as toxicity
um overall response as well as toxicity and this is also including some lab
and this is also including some lab
and this is also including some lab studies which will help us understand
studies which will help us understand
studies which will help us understand the biology of the disease as well
the biology of the disease as well
the biology of the disease as well including gvh markers um microbiome
including gvh markers um microbiome
including gvh markers um microbiome samples and um it could help us to
samples and um it could help us to
samples and um it could help us to determine which of these patients would
determine which of these patients would
determine which of these patients would or wouldn't respond
where's the field heading uh with msc so
where's the field heading uh with msc so now the um there's a phase three trial
now the um there's a phase three trial
now the um there's a phase three trial that is led by bmtctn uh testing uh
that is led by bmtctn uh testing uh
that is led by bmtctn uh testing uh testing the what is approved the
testing the what is approved the
testing the what is approved the rhinoceros in the adult setting for uh
rhinoceros in the adult setting for uh
rhinoceros in the adult setting for uh steroid refractory acute gvhd
steroid refractory acute gvhd
steroid refractory acute gvhd we know globally now that there is
we know globally now that there is
we know globally now that there is multiple products that are
multiple products that are
multiple products that are already approved the main uh you know
already approved the main uh you know
already approved the main uh you know studies have been on acute gvhd however
studies have been on acute gvhd however
studies have been on acute gvhd however there are multiple trials now to show
there are multiple trials now to show
there are multiple trials now to show that there is actually benefit of mscs
that there is actually benefit of mscs
that there is actually benefit of mscs in chronic gvhd as well
in chronic gvhd as well
in chronic gvhd as well there are trials to show that we're
there are trials to show that we're
there are trials to show that we're looking at mscs for prevention of gvh
looking at mscs for prevention of gvh
looking at mscs for prevention of gvh this has been published in just the
this has been published in just the
this has been published in just the recent one in jco they're looking at
recent one in jco they're looking at
recent one in jco they're looking at mscs derived from cord blood
mscs derived from cord blood
mscs derived from cord blood specifically for haploidentical
specifically for haploidentical
specifically for haploidentical transplants as well as another one in
transplants as well as another one in jama oncology and the primary endpoint
jama oncology and the primary endpoint
jama oncology and the primary endpoint for these studies are two-year chronic
for these studies are two-year chronic
for these studies are two-year chronic gvhd and they have actually reached the
gvhd and they have actually reached the
gvhd and they have actually reached the primary endpoint as you can see
primary endpoint as you can see
primary endpoint as you can see so in conclusion mscs are unique they
so in conclusion mscs are unique they
so in conclusion mscs are unique they have unique properties that they make
have unique properties that they make
have unique properties that they make them appropriate for treatment of gvhd
them appropriate for treatment of gvhd
them appropriate for treatment of gvhd they are an ideal off-the-shelf
they are an ideal off-the-shelf
they are an ideal off-the-shelf solution and they continue to need to
solution and they continue to need to
solution and they continue to need to improve the efficacy and to optimize
improve the efficacy and to optimize
improve the efficacy and to optimize mscs as a product
mscs as a product
mscs as a product and with that i thank you for your
and with that i thank you for your
and with that i thank you for your attention